[Música]
Estados Unidos liberó a los dos sobrinos
de la primera dama venezolana y que
habían sido detenidos en 2017 y
condenados en Nueva York por
narcotráfico la medida se dio a cambio
de la liberación de siete ciudadanos
estadounidenses encarcelados en
Venezuela
protestas en Ecuador cientos de personas
salieron a las calles de Quito para
denunciar La ola de feminicidios y
exigir garantías para la protección de
las mujeres la manifestación se da tras
el asesinato de María Belén Bernal quien
fue encontrada muerta tras visitar a su
esposo en una escuela policial
los principales candidatos a la
presidencia de Brasil cerraron su último
día de actividades de campaña de Cara a
las elecciones y a las que 156 millones
de personas están llamadas a votar en
nuestra serie de informes especiales les
contamos en qué contexto se dan estos
comicios
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias de
América en francés 24 los saluda Andrés
Meza Muñoz empezamos con una noticia que
involucra a Estados Unidos y Venezuela
el presidente Joe biden emitió una orden
de perdón y Liberación para dos
ciudadanos venezolanos se trata de los
dos sobrinos de la primera dama
venezolana cilia flores que fueron
condenados en Nueva York que en 2017 a
cumplir 18 años de prisión por
narcotráfico la orden fue firmada hace
semanas pero no se conoció hasta este
sábado a cambio de su Liberación
Venezuela dejó libres también a siete
ciudadanos estadounidenses así se
pronunció la Casa Blanca al respecto
hoy después de años de estar detenidos
injustamente en Venezuela traemos a casa
a Jorge Toledo tomeubadell alirio
Zambrano José Luis Zambrano José Pereyra
Matthew Head y osman can estas personas
pronto se reunirán con sus familias y
volverán a estar en los brazos de sus
seres queridos donde pertenecen estoy
agradecido por el arduo trabajo de los
servidores públicos dedicados en todo el
gobierno de los Estados Unidos que
hicieron esto posible y que continúan
cumpliendo con el compromiso
inquebrantable de mi administración de
mantener la fe en los estadounidenses
Rehenes y detenidos y justamente en todo
el mundo
previamente hablamos desde Caracas con
nuestra corresponsal Daniela Zambrano
quien nos contó En qué contexto de las
relaciones entre Estados Unidos y
Venezuela se da este intercambio
bueno el propio comunicado que emitió el
gobierno de Nicolás maduro dijo que
estas liberaciones eran producto de las
conversaciones que iniciaron en marzo de
este año cuando recordemos que una
delegación de alto funcionarios de
Estados Unidos visitó Caracas con total
hermetismo y en el que se conversaron
también de aliviar sanciones económicas
a Venezuela para un eventual intercambio
petrolero también recordemos que en mayo
de este año se levantaron las sanciones
que pesaban sobre otros sobrino de la
pareja presidencial que fue tesorero
nacional Carlos malpica y se relajaron
un poco las sanciones que pesaban sobre
la estatal pdvsa para poder iniciar
conversaciones con Chevron para una
eventuales actividades petroleras
recordemos que todas estas reanudación o
conversaciones que se han reanudado
entre el gobierno de Nicolás maduro y el
gobierno de John Bieber se ha manejado
con total secretismo
creo que en enero 2019 públicamente
Nicolás Maduro rompiera relaciones con
Estados Unidos bajo la administración de
Donald Trump por este reconocer a Juan
guaidó como presidente interino en otras
noticias de Venezuela las intensas
lluvias registradas en el país han
afectado a más de un millar de familias
en cuatro estados del Oeste Durante los
últimos meses así lo reportaron las
autoridades regionales en el estado
Mérida por ejemplo no ha dejado de
llover desde abril según informó su
gobernador y quien agregó que unas 65
familias perdieron totalmente sus
viviendas en imágenes se ve como las
fuertes corrientes cubren las calles y
han destrozado carreteras enteras las
precipitaciones también han causado la
pérdida de cultivos agrícolas
porque no podía pasar por ahí como vamos
a Ecuador cientos de mujeres Se tomaron
las calles de Quito para rechazar los
casos de feminicidios y exigir
protección ante la ola de violencia
machista con pancartas y retratos de
mujeres asesinadas las manifestantes
arremetieron contra la Policía Nacional
a la que acusaron de desatención y falta
de políticas efectivas para garantizar
sus derechos la movilización se dio en
el marco de la investigación por el
asesinato de la abogada María Belén
Bernal quien fue encontrada muerta
después de visitar a su esposo el
principal sospechoso en una escuela
policial de acuerdo con medios locales
en Ecuador una mujer es asesinada cada
28 horas
en este día nos damos cita por luchar
contra este gobierno
feminicida transfemicina que cada vez
nos mata y viola a nuestros derechos
porque a nosotros no nos cuida a los
policías nos matan nos Asesinan día a
día porque el estado nos lleva al
momento más de 210 mujeres que han sido
Víctimas de femicidio producto de la
inoperancia de políticas públicas de la
falta de Cuidado de las mujeres y la
vida de las mujeres en este estado
hetero normal y patriarcal Brasil
acogerá a su o escogerá a su presidente
en solo unas horas y más de 156 millones
de personas están llamadas a la cita son
un total de
447,000 mesas en todo el país y hasta
este sábado los funcionarios electorales
continuaban instalando las máquinas de
votación electrónica Brasil adoptó estos
artefactos en 1996 para poner fin al
fraude generalizado relacionado con las
papeletas son en total 11 candidatos
entre los que destacan el presidente
yare bolsonaro quien busca y el ex
presidente Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
ambos realizaron actos de cierre en Sao
Paulo sin ninguno de los aspirantes
logra reunir más del 50% del apoyo de
los electores los dos más votados irán a
una segunda vuelta el próximo 30 de
octubre veamos el informe de Rafael
Pérez
una última aparición de Los favoritos
antes de la jornada electoral en Brasil
nula y bolsonaro se midieron en un pulso
de masas el presidente y candidato a la
reelección Jair bolsonaro se hizo
presente en Sao Paulo para participar en
una caravana de motocicletas
sus seguidores se muestran preocupados
ante la idea del mandatario de que puede
existir un fraude en el sufragio de este
domingo
Ya apareció en internet hay unas que ya
están decididas para anular a la
oposición No digo que sea cierto o no
solo digo que he visto en internet si
este tipo de cosas fueran ciertas
probablemente se complicarían las cosas
Pero aún así Nosotros somos muy muy
numerosos en todas partes de Brasil hay
un número muy muy grande en todos los
lugares de Brasil dirige el país desde
2018 el ex capitán del ejército de 67
años moviliza en su mayoría a los
brasileños más conservadores
por su parte en la misma ciudad del
candidato de izquierda Luis Ignacio Lula
da Silva congregó a sus partidarios en
lo que llamó el Paseo de la Victoria El
Elegido por el partido de los
trabajadores y dos veces ex presidente
del país se mostró junto de sus delfines
políticos el aspirante a la gobernación
de Sao Pablo Fernando hadad
soy partidaria de Lula desde que era
pequeña puse mis fuerzas para que Lula
sea presidente y adad gobernador porque
Brasil necesita ser un país civilizado
como su gente Brasil es hermoso
según las encuestas él también líder
sindical lleva la delantera en la
intención de Voto dos de las
encuestadoras más importantes del país y
datafolia mostraron una intención de
votos del 51 y 50 por ciento
respectivamente hacia Lula con un margen
de error de dos puntos porcentuales
pasamos a Estados Unidos este sábado
Fuentes médicas de Florida elevaron a 47
el número de Muertos tras el paso del
huracán Ian por el estado donde tocó
tierra esta semana con categoría 4 sin
embargo se cree que la cifra podría ser
el triple la guardia costera continúas
las labores de rescate en botes y
helicópteros en zonas que siguen
sumergidas en agua y lodo expertos
aseguran que las pérdidas por las
inundaciones podrían alcanzar los 15 mil
millones de dólares y ya se disipó sobre
Virginia este sábado después de haberse
degradado en un ciclón tropical de otra
parte el presidente joeyden anunció que
visitará Puerto Rico el lunes y Florida
el miércoles para evaluar los daños
y un robot que hace distintas
actividades humanas desde regar las
plantas hasta levantar barras de metal
en empresas es el prototipo que está
desarrollando la compañía tesla y lo más
sencillo presentó al humanoide Optimus y
dijo que espera que su compañía comience
a recibir pedidos entre 3 a 5 años para
comprar el robot Espera que puedan
venderlo por 20 mil dólares es decir
casi un tercio del precio actual del
modelo
y cerramos con imágenes de un peculiar
festival celebrado en Albuquerque en
Estados Unidos se trata de un Festival
Internacional de globos aerostáticos una
fiesta anual que se lleva a cabo desde
hace 50 años en el desierto de Nuevo
México y que reúne a pilotos y
espectadores de todo el mundo este año
están representados en más de 20 países
como Suiza Australia Brasil Croacia
México Taiwán y Ucrania
de esta manera despedimos este
Informativo en frases 24 Gracias por
acompañarnos continúen con toda nuestra
programación
[Música]